US Army sergeant Bowe Bergdahl is
awaiting sentencing after pleading
guilty to desertion and misbehavior
before the enemy which could land him in
prison for life we'll discuss how Barack
Obama got us into this mess then AM
Baratheon his eminence Paul Bois joined
the panel of deplorable z-- to talk
about the whoa cue pen ta who refuses to
call on her white male students lucky
kids vicious dictator and World Health
Organization goodwill ambassador Robert
Mugabe and snoop diggity Doo Depp's
latest hip hop ditty make America [ __ ]
again I'm Michael Knowles and this is
the Michael Noel's show
[Music]
we have so much to get to today we have
to analyze this Bo Bergdahl thing
because everybody forgets about these
really important political moments like
five minutes after they pass and they
let Barack Obama off the hook so we have
to get to that but first this is a very
good day because we have a new sponsor
Marshall you still have a job for
another week we have a sponsor the
lights were on
we've got Skillshare Skillshare is an
excellent sponsor one nice thing about
doing this show other than your not
having to do any like we're actual work
anymore and just talking all day is that
we get free trials of a lot of these
great products Skillshare is the one
that is going to change my life and
it'll probably change yours too it is
it's a basically like the Netflix for
learning new things so you know if you
want to get a leg up at work if you want
to take your career to the next level or
if you just want a side hustle you know
you've got your job you like your job
but you've got a hobby that you're doing
maybe you want to make little money on
the side or for me you want to get
better at everything you're doing you've
got to check out Skillshare they have a
gazillion classes they have over three
million members and more than 17,000
classes that's a real number 17 classes
at your disposal if you sign up you know
it's it's the Netflix for online
learning classes in graphic design DSLR
photography social media marketing
digital illustration and much more they
have classes in writing which I'm now
going to need to take obviously and now
that I'm required to write an actual
book with words so I'm looking into that
one they're taught by industry experts
experienced professionals there they're
great if you're gonna build your career
or you trying out something new the ones
that I really like are all about how to
get faster at doing the things you
already do so I read slowly they have
multiple classes on speed reading on how
to just like inject your brain with
knowledge skill share itself is
basically an example of this you know
they'll have a three minute course on
how to pick up the basics of a language
they're really really good so whatever
you want to do design photography
marketing entrepreneurship check it out
skill share is giving my listeners a
one-month free trial of unlimited access
to 17,000 classes so it's not like you
get to try one
and then two lessons in you have to pay
a lot of money or something you get a
month completely free these classes are
pretty quick so you can get a lot of
knowledge in you would be a big dummy if
you don't take advantage of this if you
know you can lead a horse to water but
you can't make them learn a bunch of new
skills go over there right now go to
Skillshare comm slash michael it's
important to put in much slash michael
mi CH AE l because then they'll know
that we sent you and then we get to keep
the lights on and I get to keep cuff fa
in my mug so be sure to go over there
Skillshare comm slash michael and start
your free month trial today okay alright
now we have to get into the news we've
got this Bo Bergdahl story he has
pleaded guilty and I don't know if you
remember him but Bowe Bergdahl is the
deserter for whom Barack Obama traded
five extremely dangerous Taliban
operatives he was being held by the
Taliban he dumped a lot of guys at a
Gitmo high-profile terrorists to get
this guy back Trump has called Bergdahl
a traitor who should be executed in
typical trumpian nuance and we're
awaiting the sentencing now but it's
easy to gloss over all of this recent
history let's be clear Barack Obama's
radicalism and an epic ineptitude rather
is what got us here six Americans died
looking for this guy when he deserted
his post five high-profile terrorists
are back in the region so you know it's
a win-win by Barack Obama standards and
I don't
I actually don't mean that
disrespectfully or glibly this is the
deal he wanted he this is the art of the
deal according to Barack Obama we'll get
into why he wanted this deal later but a
traitor a deserter back in our country
and five terrorists back on the
battlefield Barack Obama thought this
was a good idea so let's go to Barack
Obama announcing Bergdahl's return in
2014 good afternoon everybody
this morning I called Bob and Jani
Bergdahl and told them that after nearly
five years in captivity their son Beau
is coming home sergeant Bergdahl has
missed birthdays and holidays and the
simple moments with family and friends
which all of us take for granted
but while beau was gone he was never
forgotten his parents thought about him
and prayed for him every single day as
did his sister Skye who prayed for his
safe return
he wasn't forgotten by his community in
Idaho or the military which rallied to
support the Bergdahl's through thick and
thin and he wasn't forgotten by his
country because the United States of
America does not ever leave our men and
women in uniform behind that's the key
so you see during this press conference
he's careful with his language he
doesn't say this is a great hero we're
welcoming a hero home because he knows
the guy's a deserter he knows that the
guys responsible for six American
soldiers being killed trying to find him
but he's building the case for why we
had to trade these these huge assets
that were being held at Guantanamo Bay
why we had to send them back to Qatar so
that we could get this deserter back in
our midst
and the last line is the key he said we
never as Americans we never leave our
guys on the battlefield even if they're
deserters even if they're traitors we
don't leave them back on the battlefield
this isn't exactly true there is a
tradition of this going back even to the
French and Indian War even before the
country was founded where we always go
and and that's sort of the agreement you
enlist to serve the country and we make
sure that we don't leave you behind that
this has not always worked out in
practice as a does in theory during the
Civil War there the the Union military
made attempts to rescue thousands of
captured soldiers who were being held in
the south the the South had this idea
which was if they captured a black Union
soldier they would enslave him so the
the Union Army halted all prisoner
exchanges until the South agreed to
treat black soldiers the same way they
treated white soldiers this this
resulted in about 13,000 Union soldiers
being killed and dying excuse me while
in Confederate captivity we didn't go
and get them there were certain other
considerations that we had to take into
account obviously things are not that
simple it's not an automatic rule at the
moment someone is is in captivity we
send out this battalion and this group
of people that they're considering
that have to be made by the military
leadership by the civilian leadership in
World War two Americans were being held
POWs in Hiroshima and Nagasaki
you might remember those two cities
because we vaporized them we blew them
to bits
the United States government made that
decision knowing that there may very
well be American prisoners being held
there but obviously they took into
account the million American soldiers
who could have died trying to island hop
in the in Japan trying to go
conventionally and defeat Japan finally
so they made that decision but there
were POWs who got zapped because we had
to make certain decisions and because
our enemies behaved in a certain way you
know on the other side there have been
tremendous raids there was the rate at
Caban to one I'm sure I'm butchering
that in the Philippines during that war
American forces went into the heart of
Japanese forces to save 500 Americans
I'm not suggesting that we're not we
don't do this but it isn't nearly as
clear-cut as Barack Obama needs to
pretend it is to justify his terrible
decision he goes on as part of this
effort the United States is transferring
five detainees from the prison in
Guantanamo Bay to Qatar the Qatari
government has given us assurances that
it will put in place measures to protect
our national security
he's gonna try to all this straight face
for that the Qatari government is
because the Qatari gut we can really
rely on these guys right they're gonna
protect American national security one
of the largest state sponsors of
terrorism in the world it tied to the
Eleonora front tied to al-qaeda tied to
Hamas tied to Isis they don't worry
folks we're gonna send back some of the
most high-profile terrorists in the
world to one of the largest state
sponsors of terror in the world and one
of the richest countries in the region
but it's okay probably not nothing will
happen it'll all go just fine he goes on
I'd like to say to Beau right now who's
having trouble speaking English
piecemeal ar-rahman ar-rahim say ah BM
I'm your father bow
people of Afghanistan the same Khalifa
al-thani
the complicated nature of this recovery
was will never really be complemented
comprehended
so that was Bowe Bergdahl's father
speaking at that press conference
Obama has Bergdahl's parents on either
side of him and I'm not gonna beat up on
him too much his son was taken captive I
don't know what goes through a guy's
head I don't know what drives him to
think the things he does or behave the
way he does he doesn't folk a lot at
this press conference which raised a lot
of eyebrows he does have a very kind of
terrorist he looking beard that he grew
out ostensibly to understand what his
son was going through perfectly
understandable
there was a deleted tweet that he had
sent out which said quote I am still
working to free all Guantanamo prisoners
God will repay for the death of every
Afghan child I mean he also retweeted a
bunch of enemy propaganda about the
United States this was not a good
looking press conference for Barack
Obama and it raises a lot of questions
was Bowe Bergdahl sympathizing with the
enemy when he was Afghanistan's that
would prompted him to desert what are
his parents his father at least seems to
have been sympathizing with the enemy
during the captivity that we can't
really know it all as Bergdahl's father
says it was a complicated process to get
this guy out I think that is the
understatement of the century the
complications that he's alluding to here
are ideological complications both for
Barack Obama's radical ideology and
perhaps the ideology of those who are
sympathizing with the enemy here is is
Mike Flynn before he was thrown under
the bus because of this Russia probe
here's Mike Flynn who had knowledge of
the circumstances explaining it so for
the first 24 to 72 hours I mean we were
in crisis operations and we were I was
personally diverting every single
capability human intelligence wise to
signals intelligence to unmanned aerial
vehicles to space-based systems I mean
we really turned on to find this soldier
so you believe that
he did walk off the base of the
intention of meeting the Taliban
absolutely nobody now suggests that he
didn't at the time it was hotly disputed
he's not a deserter this is Republican
propaganda to attack President Obama now
he did he deserted he walked off of the
base Barack Obama kind of leaned into
that and defended that at the time
anyway and President Trump in his
typical understatement nuanced way made
this an issue of the campaign take
sergeant bergdhal does anybody remember
that name so so this is the way we think
so we get a traitor named Bergdahl a
dirty rotten traitor
who by the way when he deserted six
young beautiful people were killed
trying to find him right and you don't
even hear about him anymore somebody
said the other day well he had some
psychological problems well you know you
know the old days being bong when we
were strong when we were strong so we
get Bergdahl a traitor and they get five
of the people that they most wanted
anywhere in the world five killers that
are right now back on the battlefield
doing a job that's the kind of deals we
make that's the kind of deals we make
right am i right
typical trumpian surprise that would be
really bad as settlers of catan yeah
I don't even know what that game is we
got to stop hiring kids to do this show
Donald Trump is there he's got if you
couldn't hear on the bing-bong he's got
he's making the image of a rifle so he's
suggesting that we killed radar we just
execute them fair enough
the six Americans that died looking for
Bergdahl are you don't hear their names
a lot you hear both Bergdahl's name you
don't hear their names it's Staff
Sergeant Clayton Bowen private first
class Morris Walker staff sergeant Kurt
Curtis second lieutenant Darren Andrews
Staff Sergeant Michael Murphree and
private first class Matthew martynuk so
six guys go out there try
to find this guy and we trade him for
the Taliban five called by John McCain
the hardest of the hardcore all five
deemed high risk to the United States so
why did Barack Obama do it
two words Guantanamo Bay underscored and
Bowe Bergdahl's father's tweet he did it
because he made it a plank of his first
campaign to close Guantanamo Bay he said
we're gonna close it it's not
constitutional it's not in the ideals of
America we have to get rid of it it
didn't happen he realized he couldn't do
it because the worst people on the face
of the earth were being held captive
there so Barack Obama saw an excuse to
trade five terrorists for this deserter
and to bring him back I'm sure if he
could have he would have traded 10 for
the deserter because the the incentives
here were so perverse for Barack Obama
he didn't he didn't view it as a letdown
to let these people out he'd been
looking for a way to empty that prison
openly so since 2008 he campaigned on it
this is not some crazy conspiracy theory
he told us exactly what he wanted to do
and then we got as done as Donald Trump
said perfectly some of that speech that
he gave about Bowe Bergdahl was not
articulate to say the least talking
about bing bang in a dirty rotten
traitor maybe he shouldn't have used
that language but he got it exactly
right when he talked about Barack
Obama's art of the deal those are the
kind of deals that we get because of
Barack Obama's radicalism because of his
radical ideology an ideology set that
says that we are the cause of a lot of
troubles in the world we're not
protecting the world
we're causing a lot of troubles we need
to get out of other people's business we
shouldn't we can't have these awful
terrorists in Guantanamo Bay it's not
right it's wrong let them all out and
and that's the result that you get and
you know unfortunately now there's a new
sheriff in town and Bowe Bergdahl
appears to be getting what he deserves
but we'll have to wait for sentencing
before the sentencing we have to bring
on our panel we have an excellent panel
today of his Eminence Paul Bois and of
the daily callers amber Athey thanks for
coming on so your eminence
your eminence happy birthday by the way
it was your birthday on Saturday thank
you
Paul Bois was it was it worth it six
dead Americans five terrorists and
hands this sounds like a loaded question
but it really isn't because you do have
to take into account leaving a man on
the field was it worth it so that we
didn't leave this guy on the battlefield
I would say that the righteous law of
leaving no man behind fell completely
out the window the second he deserted
his his squadron and put the lives of
American soldiers at risk so I believe
the the intensity of to retrieving him
severely lowers at that point and
trading a 5/5 terrorists for him for
someone who deserted his his base and
people died as a result of it absolutely
not no but is it worth trying to get him
at least sure he's a rotten terrorist as
as Trump says but he's still our guy
even if he deserts you can't desert for
long pal we'll get you you know I mean
if maybe we shouldn't have traded five
terrorists for him but should it be the
policy of the United States to always go
after guys that we lose on the field I
would agree it still should be in our
policy and our priorities to get him
back but like I said the intensity by
which we do it severely goes down when
they desert and put other Americans at
risk fair enough and should in may be we
don't give up five of the worst guys on
earth maybe we only give up three amber
do people understand that Barack Obama
did this intentionally do people get
that this was a strategic decision or
will his radicalism be whitewashed by
history and he'll just be a sort of
amiable middle of the road or when
historians look back I don't think
people fully understand that this is
clearly just a ploy as you said to close
Guantanamo Bay because when he first
talked about doing that the normal
person's reaction was well what are you
going to do with all of these terrorists
that are there and this was a really
easy way for him to just get rid of fine
with them but the problem is that
history always looks more favorably upon
past presidents unless of course you're
George Washington or Thomas Jefferson in
which case liberals will try to tear
down your statues but I
let's look at some of the other Obama
era scandals people aren't talking about
fast and furious anymore the only reason
they're talking about Benghazi is
because they want the incident with me
jeredy Beach Trump's Benghazi so I think
this is just gonna be another example of
things being whitewashed throughout
history and Obama's going to be
considered the perfect moderate Democrat
just on that point that awful
congresswoman with the silly hats
Frederico Wilson who completely
politicized this fallen American Hero
'la David Johnson she has said that this
is Trump's Benghazi she's saying that
Trump's alleged impoliteness on the
telephone which we don't have a ton of
reason to believe was impolite because
we've heard other calls of his to gold
star families but she's saying this
alleged impoliteness this is his version
of Benghazi the best part about that
statement is that it acknowledges that
Benghazi was Benghazi it acknowledges
that that was finally a Democrat is
admitting that was a terrible scandal
that rightly plagued Hillary Clinton and
plagues her today people seem to be
missing that point that in her
criticizing Trump she's acknowledging
how bad Benghazi was herself look so
silly because she only has tweeted about
Benghazi twice she tweeted about it once
the other day when she said this was
Trump's Benghazi and then she tweeted
about it when it very first happened to
offer her condolences to the families of
the soldiers who died so there's a huge
silence in there so if she's gonna sit
here and say Benghazi was a big deal now
she's just making herself look idiotic
hold on you're telling me that a woman
who wears sequined cowboy hats on the
floor of the United States Congress she
might look a little silly I don't
believe it this is the intrepid
reporting at the Michael Knowles show
okay we've got a lot more to talk about
we've got to talk about woke TAS and
white males and Goodwill Ambassador
Robert Mugabe but you can't watch any of
that if you don't subscribe to The Daily
wire we've got to say goodbye to
Facebook and YouTube to everyone who
already subscribes thank you very much
it keeps the lights on it keeps my
coffee full of coffe fa or am i my
leftist here's tumblr rather full of CAF
fa so we really appreciate it but come
on over to the Daily wire it's ten bucks
a month one hundred dollars a year you
get me you get the Andrew Clavin show
you get the Ben Shapiro show yada yada
you who cares right who could but you
get this
you can't get this anywhere else you
just have to subscribe it's the only
place to get your tears well this it
what's it so it's always made out of the
hardest metals on earth at which we have
concocted here in The Daily wire
laboratories of crushed up Steve crater
mugs so we have King this is absolutely
the scientific cutting-edge it holds
delicious leftist tears now we're
serving up a vintage of Frederico Wilson
so we've got its really good there's
some sequins in there so watch that that
it doesn't get stuck in your teeth or
your throat but otherwise it's either
hot or cold always salty and delicious
left as tears go over to daily wired.com
right now we'll be right back
so they woke UPenn teacher won't call on
white males UPenn this is the Ivy League
by the way this isn't Penn State we're
talking about theoretically one of the
top academic universities in the country
a teaching assistant PhD student named
Stephanie MacKillop just tweeted out
quote I will always call on my black
womens students first other POC that's
people of color which for some reason
that's the nice term but Colored People
is viciously racist so but POC is that
that one's okay other people of color
get second tier priority white women
come next and if I have two white men I
believe the the tuition at the
University of Pennsylvania is like 60
grand a year right now but she won't
call on the white man in the spirit of
this woke ta Michela I'll have to call
on amber first is this intersectional
oppression ideology just the ravings of
some kook or is it widespread how
widespread is this absurd ideology it's
crazy this specific example is the first
time I've seen this but overall the
ideology behind it I think is fairly
widespread at university is what you see
is professors and these social justice
warriors they can't just have people of
different races be equal they actually
have to glorify and hold the so-called
oppressed minority classes above the
people who are historically not
oppressed in their eyes so this is just
an example of how in her view the black
women gets special treatment not just
equal treatment because they have had
some kind of injustice done to them
meanwhile while you said they are
attending one of the best schools in the
country at a super high price tagging
are probably some of the most privileged
people in society you know I believe it
the largest mass lynching in American
history was against Sicilians this is a
true story at 11 Sicilians were lynched
and I think 1891 it's one of the reasons
Columbus Day became a holiday does this
mean Shapiro has to give me a raise as a
Sicilian American is a partially
Sicilian American historically very
oppressed I don't know I'm gonna ask him
about it
Pablo yeah only if I get a raise for
being a woman well we could raise your
pain
for the Michael Nolt show panel of
deplorable z' infinitely because we here
of course paid nobody anything probably
including me
Papua isn't this just an example of
patriarchy and institutional racism
because I I never wanted to be called on
in class these kids get a free pass they
don't have to do any class participation
just the white man getting it getting
one over on everybody else yet again
yeah Michael I mean doesn't it seem a
rather counterintuitive to just make the
the white men just like sit around and
be lazy during the class and make all
the the colored students just like I
have to work extra hard it it's almost
beyond parody we're gonna we're gonna
show you a quality all you white men
came back and have a pina colada and all
you black students now you have to do
all the work might as well just raise
the curriculum for all for all the
minorities do to make them work like
super extra hard Z's actually that you
can get an A and just say do you think
that this is because I think most people
in America when they read stories like
this are shocked that this goes on but I
remember I was in college not too long
ago I was in a place just as crazy as
you been that this really is what this
is the common sense to these people it
is common sense that white male students
should be disadvantaged because of
historical and justices and the
intersectional ideology that it like it
goes you're looked at as insane if you
question that ideology how widespread is
this in elite institutions and is it
creeping down at all in the regular
culture or is the regular culture just
gonna vote for Donald Trump and say
enough of your craziness I would say yes
it is very widespread in elite
institutions I mean I went to Cal State
Northridge and even even was prevalent
there and that's a small smaller College
out here in California I can only
imagine how bad it gets in you know Ivy
League and the elite institutions like
UPenn and Yale and Harvard
it's just widespread there and then in
terms of how it trickles down to the the
broader culture I mean that that is an
interesting question I certainly think
that the institutions the cultural
institutions have bitten the Apple on
this Hollywood certainly have
major corporations Starbucks Target what
have you
they've all been and so they try and use
their institutional power to translate
it into the product culture and they
utilize it to beat people with a club
and say oh you know what we're woke if
you if you you want to be woke like us
you know you want to be you want to be
cool and hip or you know unless you you
want to be one of those deplorable z--
over there then you better sign on to
this whole white privilege and gender
intersectionality narrative so that's
really how they try to translate into
the broader culture and that's why I
think we'd like to Trump to set tell all
of those people screw you woke like blah
that should be the title of your memoir
that's really beautiful
speaking of coolness and hip Ness oh no
I'm sorry well kids of that story after
we're gonna stop talking about snoop
diddly doodad later but we have to first
talk about Robert Mugabe the goodwill
ambassador Robert Mugabe has been named
by the World Health Organization a
goodwill ambassador the director said
quote I am honored to be joined by
President Mugabe of Zimbabwe a country
that places universal health coverage
and health promotion at the center of
its policies to provide health care to
all that's from w-h-o director-general
Ted Rose HOD Hanauma and he told that to
a global health care conference as the
w-h-o made its announcement in Zimbabwe
one in three children are starving
Mugabe is the oldest leader or really
just dictator in the entire world he
enjoys being compared to Hitler
he has constantly rigged elections he
even won quote unquote this in Bob
William Lottery in 2000 he said that
whites are second-class citizens in
Zimbabwe and that they're better dead
this is the guy who was a goodwill
ambassador for the w-h-o whu-oh we will
point out has since rescinded its offer
Bob wha does this prove that
multinational organizations like the WH
o the United Nations that they're just
mouthpieces for dictators as we on the
right have claimed for decades yeah
Michael I'm actually kind of surprised
they they kicked him out because he fits
right in I mean this is an organization
who one of their founding members was
Stalin well I mean this is an
organization on their 70th anniversary
they parade a bunch of dictators to talk
about the
the importance of dignity and human
rights people you know leaders of China
and Cuba it's it's an organization half
of their 193 members are deemed by human
rights groups to be not even free at all
and in violation of every human rights
lynching what we have
yeah human rights principle we have on
record so yeah I mean I my opinion of
the of the UN is just basically disband
them as an organization just keep them
as just like a forum for nations to come
and you know debate about their spit
spats but everything else is pretty much
useless turn it into luxury condos
there's a great cigar bar nearby called
the cigar in on 53rd and second turn
into luxury condos maybe I get one there
someday it'll be closer to my favorite
stogie spot and you have made a good
point
your eminence mr. Bois because I've
never heard someone make a positive case
for Mugabe
but compared to Stalin Robert Mugabe is
pretty good better Robert Mugabe better
than Stalin ambassador amber doesn't
this highlight the absurdity of liberals
do this all the time lefties do this all
the time they point to places with
crushing poverty and corruption like
Cuba and they lured them for so-called
universal health care universal health
care that doesn't have any medicine
that's rife with corruption that no one
gets to access say I was in Havana some
locals pointed to the hospital they said
there it is anybody can go in and you
have to bring your own medicine and your
own tools because they won't have any
there you have to basically bribe
doctors to work on you because the
doctors don't make any money either
doesn't every tin pot dictator and every
banana republic around the world have a
whole host of goods that don't don't
ever seem to materialize that's exactly
right I mean you can say whatever you
want when you're a dictator because you
also have to imagine the press and the
military on your side so the real story
never really gets out there and you're
right that liberals will often overlook
the real story behind these promises
because they're so desperate to prove
that socialism and communism are
beneficial ideologies back when Fidel
Castro died I went to American
University speaking of crazy social
justice warriors and I interviewed them
and I asked them if they thought that
Fidel Castro or Donald Trump was a
better leader and they all almost all of
them said that they preferred Fidel
Castro you might notice they cited the
yeah they say cited like you said the
apparent universal health care and they
cited the high literacy rates were which
are also shown to not be accurate so
they're just they have no examples of
actual working communism or socialism
but because they keep pushing for it in
the u.s. they have to just go by what
these dictators are saying which is a
really distorted version of reality and
they have the press on their side as you
say the press is so key here and it must
be what it feels like for Barack Obama
to have CNN you know for Mugabe that
this is in Bob we impress our Pravda for
the Soviets or something like that that
is and that's the worry when we talk
about fake news the worry isn't I don't
think there's any worry right now that
we're gonna ban the media outlets in the
United States the worry is that they're
sycophants for Democrats the worry is
that they're just machine guns for the
Democratic Party there are
communications firm flacking for them
and that that's no good I mean that's no
different than Pravda so we got to knock
them well we can okay moving on to the
most important news hip hop crooner
Snoop Doggy puff has a new piece out on
our fearless leader it's called make
America [ __ ] again now I wanted to play
this clip of the random noises and
cacophony that he calls a musical piece
but unfortunately there's so much so
much expletive in it that we can't do it
on the show the only yeah just be a
bleep it just be along bleep so I can
quote the lyrics Snoop Snoopy says the
president wants to make America great
again if that we gonna make America [ __ ]
again [ __ ] referring to the gang that I
guess he was associated with now this is
a marked change in hip-hop hip-hop is
turning on President Trump now but
hip-hop used to love Trump because he
was a symbol of conspicuous wealth and
success and something to aspire to
so a young musician named Young Jeezy
once warbled quote and I'm gonna change
a couple words because I don't want to
get yelled at
quote richest ninja in my hood call me
Donald Trump there were 318 mentions
according to
Nate silver at 538 of Donald Trump
between 1989 and 2016 amber why does
hip-hop not like Donald Trump anymore
well because he's a Republican I mean
it's fairly obvious these rappers are
good buddies with Barack Obama and I
guess to some extent Hillary Clinton
although I don't think she's quite hip
enough for most of them but the part
that really got me about Snoop Dogg's
rap is mentioning he wants to make
America [ __ ] again he explained that the
Crips were originally founded to be sort
of the new Black Panther Party obviously
what they ended up being was a very
violent gang in California so for him to
lecture about Donald Trump being a
terrible person and with Eminem to both
enter promote gang culture is a bit
absurd
I would think snoops also a drive-by
shooting criminals so you know I mean
it's at least it's of a piece when he
says we want to make pun intended that
he wants to make America [ __ ] again Bob
wah is there anything redeeming about
this terrible music because I try you
know people say I'm like an old
curmudgeon I sound like a caricature of
just an old Republican who's like you
kids with your hip-hop but it's horrible
it's just not good I have so frequently
tried to convince myself that hip-hop
songs are like are good or in any way
but I can't they're just terrible
is there anything redeeming about it
well as Aristotle said Michael Aristotle
said Michael music gives soul to the
universe and to be quite honest I've
always found hip-hop to be a very
miserable genre of music it won its way
to carnal of a genre it just it's all
about just just the beat itself and
that's why if you listen to even like a
quote-unquote good hip hop song you're
pretty much bored with it within like to
two or three days and you never really
want to return to listen to whatever
again so that's one thing but in terms
of the culture that it's bred especially
when you look at previous musician black
musicians of previous generation you had
soul music you had gentlemen like a Nat
King Cole so such a beautiful music that
contributed so wonderfully to the
American Songbook and and there's
nothing that's going to be remembered
in hip-hop fifty years from now it's
just gonna be considered just like oh
yeah a music genre that came in right
but nobody's gonna be returning to your
classics of Snoop Dogg you know singing
about money on his mind 50 years from
now and and you know the horrible
culture of misogyny that it breads so I
look forward to its death
completely you're a hopeless optimist
rather I think they probably will be
looking back on these guys and you
mentioned the how carnal the music is
it's all about sex and treating women
terribly but you know you bring up soul
music to soul music is extremely sensual
in some ways carnal but soul music is
great there are a lot of excellent songs
in Soul and Motown that kind of take you
on a journey and they're musically
somewhat sophisticated and lyrically
compelling and this stuff is just
garbage
so I even tried I've tried to listen to
Kanye one time because everyone told me
well mostly Kanye just told me he's the
greatest musical genius ever so I
decided to see if he was right and the
thing is he is sort of good in that he
has good taste in music
so he samples good songs and then he
makes them worse by singing on them so
like even even wrote a song with Paul
McCartney write a couple songs one is
called only one which is really good Kim
Kardashian said it was her favorite
Kanye song
it's her favorite Kanye song because
Paul McCartney wrote it and then he and
it sounds really good except for Kanye's
awful voice but I think that's that's
the trouble maybe they have a good sense
of music but just they don't have any
talents so it produces this garbage and
but we'll have to tie that into maybe
one of Andrew Klavan segments are crappy
culture okay panel of deplorable z--
thank you for being here excellent to
have you amber Athey from The Daily
Caller his eminence Paul Bois coming to
us from outside of time and space and
also from the daily wire speaking of
Andrew Clavin you got to go over and
check out our new narrative podcast
Hollywood is in rubble and we're
thrilled about that so we have this it's
Andrews new story called another Kingdom
it's about a totally failed guy in
Hollywood failed screenwriter who
wanders into another dimension and finds
out he's the suspect in a murder with a
bloody dagger in his hand and a dead
body at his feet it's really fun we
released it a couple weeks ago thanks to
everyone who's listened and left a
review
we've got like hundreds of reviews now
up on iTunes they're all five-star
except for one to star review I think
that's my third cousin once-removed
Hillary Clinton so sorry Hillary I'm
sorry you didn't like it if you go over
there please subscribe and leave a
review that really helps us out
I think we were number 12 in arts on
iTunes over the weekend so it's the cure
to the clayvin last weekend and if you
don't like crappy culture like snoop
diddly dude app then listen to our show
and it's pretty compelling I think and
also the last roll that I'll ever have
in Hollywood other than that get your
mailbag questions in that's gonna be on
Thursday we will change your life
forever and then that's our show come
back tomorrow we'll do it all again
I am Michael Knowles this is the Michael
Knowles show
[Music]
[Music]